get ready to see a lot more of that on  your TV screens fuller house star jodie  sweetin has officially joined the cast  of a dancing with the stars upcoming at  22nd season and can you tell us who your  dance partner will bite your hand I'm  dancing with key oh yes Oh gonna be  great together yeah how far are you  rehearsing czar you uh we have just had  the first couple days so Jody previously  told ET she might be interested in  taking on the ballroom I mean it's a  wonderful rumor and I think it's a huge  compliment to have my name even thrown  in the Hat you know the casting news  came down the same day netflix announced  more for houses headed our way to the  streaming service has picked up a second  season of the sitcom